the American political system works with
question is who is it working for it's
working for the oil companies it's
working for the mining companies it's
working for the banks and it's working
for the utilities and it's working for
the insurance companies and it's
certainly working for the pharmaceutical
companies so the system works the
question is who does it work for now I
can tell you it doesn't work for it
doesn't work for middle America it
doesn't work for working families it
doesn't work for single mothers it
doesn't work for small business owners
there's a lot of people doesn't work for
and what I'm determined to do as
president of the United States is to
make sure that we have a government that
works for everyone now one of the
reasons why government doesn't work for
people is there is much of a difference
between the two political parties the
Democrats and Republicans at the top
really are pretty much the same
you